futur plus en forme de vigilance de
niveau jaune de la vienne et vous invite
à suivre l'évolution de la situation sur
le site internet
ce message sébastien proulx tall a reçu
hier en fin de matinée sur son téléphone
une alerte aux crues de la vienne
beaucoup trop tardive pour cet
agriculteur car la veille la rivière
était déjà sorti de son lit montant par
endroits jusqu'à 5 mètres de hauteur
c'est complètement étonnant c c'est ce
qui nous même type aujourd'hui on en est
très motion dans notre colère être
prévenu 24 heures après d'une éventuelle
crue et pour juger des conséquences
aujourd'hui on est plutôt en colère
quand on filme en ce système d' alerte
contre les services de l'état qui a pas
fait son boulot il ya un manquement
évident car pour se prémunir des risques
de crues les agriculteurs consulte
vigicrues un site d'information éditée
par le ministère de la transition
écologique autrement dit l'état
cet exploitant agricole qui utilisent
également ce service n'a pas non plus
été alertés à temps de la brusque montée
de la vienne dont le débit a été presque
multiplié par 10 en quelques heures au
midi avait pas encore de de crue est
malheureusement j'étais palaja jour là
mais j'ai été prévenu par mes voisins
heureusement et quand je suis arrivé ici
vers 17 heures on était à peu près à ce
niveau là vous avez déjà vu ça jamais je
n'ai jamais vu l'arrivée à monté aussi
rapidement
conséquence pour ce professionnel et
pour des dizaines d'autres alentours son
matériel d'irrigation a été tout
bonnement englouti par les eaux des
pontes dont le coût avoisine les 4000
euros et qui sont essentiels en période
estivale avec la pluie qu'on a eu on est
on est peut-être encore une quinzaine de
jours tranquilles sans irriguées mais la
suivant les dégâts dans quinze jours on
sera certainement pas dépanner contactée
la préfecture d'indre et loire n'a
souhaité faire aucun commentaire
la crue quand elles ne devraient pas
avoir trop d'impact sur les cultures
peut être moins d'ailleurs que les
pluies de ce mois de juillet décidément
bien maussade